I lived in New York City for years and
it has some of the best food in the
world I invited my friend Harry Kirsch
over from the UK to teach him how we do
things slightly differently here we'll
be visiting four of the top Burger spots
across the city all in one day to see if
we can find New York's best burger this
is Food Tours
first stop of the day JG melon
hi buddy today we're having the best
burgers in New York City how you feeling
I'm excited I guess it may be my
favorite food thank goodness well
starting here J.G melon have you heard
of the sports I have no no tell me more
it wouldn't start here because this
place does Burgers traditionally you
know like Smash Burgers and like piling
and high with ridiculous topics no here
they serve the double beef warm griddle
cooked Burgers they do it simple cheese
onions you make a little bacon on ours
simple ingredients simple setup gonna
taste amazing yeah the vibing here I'd
say it's like pretty traditional it's
quite low-key old school Decor don't
accept cards which is annoying but I run
I get some cash but um yeah I'd say the
menu is like fairly simple classic
nothing too flashy on here nah I feel
like you were pretty impressed by UK
Burgers when we were touring London yeah
it was we had Fantastic Burgers but I
mean
it's next level here in the city I don't
know how else I can put it I'm excited
to see well I imagine to be a pretty
traditional American cheeseburger The
Taste is going to blow your mind I
guarantee it
look at these
yeah is there anything else I could
bring you to thanks so much
they have not skimped on the bacon no
they have not they've not skept under
thickness I mean come on man you're not
getting anything thick like that in the
UK this is ridiculous the only thing in
the UK Thicker Than This Is Me
okay what do you think that you get the
American bacon today I'm just done I'm
getting the American bacon today too
buddy you got that crispy then I feel
like often when you get bacon on a
burger you get the full strips I hate
that I quite like this because they've
kind of like diced this up yes so
therefore I guess when you bite into it
you're not just gonna accidentally tear
the whole Burger out optimal eating get
some of this onion on here there you go
come on I'm putting the pickles on I
know you're not a pickles guy Cheese
look at that it's melted right to the
burgers done to perfection dude oh my
God I'm so excited yeah I can't really
wait anymore should we just crack in
yeah let's crack in all right man
mmm
oh
no it's absolutely fantastic Burger
uh-huh perfect flavor did you get that
like juice just pouring out
look at that on the inside yeah that is
medium rare perfect Perfecto the one
thing that's really impressive to me is
that
it doesn't feel like too dense I would
say yeah when you're forming the patties
sometimes there's too much of a
temptation to really like pack the meat
in there and you end up with a much
chewier texture whereas this is still
like so melt in your mouth soft it's
really really impressive how does this
compare to like UK burgers on a home
good question
thank you yeah
so I'm a journalist
asking questions is kind of my job the
fact that you like that one really means
a lot to me hot craze I think one thing
that's standing out to me is the way
it's cooked I don't think it's super
common in the UK for someone to actually
ask you how you want your burger cooked
unless you're at a slightly more
high-end restaurant yes I think that
generally implies that they're using
fresher ingredients everything is being
cooked to order
and I think the end result there is a
really fresh juicy burger I totally
agree it tastes like it's thick it's
juicy the meat was so perfectly packed
crazy good back there they got like the
the broiler that kind of finishes the
cook of the meat right before they put
the burger in there that's when they add
the cheese and the cheese on the grill
on The Griddle it's almost like they're
broiling the cheese to the uh the Patty
genius move so it's almost like Saran
wraps with cheese the delicious flavor
and also adheres the cheese to the meats
the place man come on I feel like I've
seen I'm in the 70s right now in New
York I'm I'm in the Midtown Manhattan
yeah I'm in a big thick Burger cup of
coffee I was gonna say this place feels
even older than the 70s maybe this feels
like a really retro face I mean like a
complimentary way yeah very old school
retro Vibe yeah I mean this is where you
go for a long lunch a couple of drinks
burgers with the co-workers you go back
to the office and do literally nothing
no work
this might be the one to beat I know
we're just starting but it's laid down a
gauntlet already I will say I know we've
got more Burger Street today but yeah
yeah this is getting finished again man
I'm sorry okay
I warned him
Harry and I had some time to kill before
next spot so we took a stroll through
Central Park Harry saw a turtle
from there we made our way to another
New York Burger State PJ clemx new spot
PJ Clarks right it's a New York Burger
institution I know there's a lot of
facts here but one fact I think is
hilarious is that uh Buddy Holly
proposed to his wife here and it was
their first date
that's moving a little bit fast yeah I
think he was just I don't know I mean
maybe he knew oh also something this is
Sinatra's joint he always said a table
20. West table 20. I want to sit on the
Sinatra table I think this is it right
here no this camera so it's like a it's
a jazz legend hangout yeah dude this has
been here since 1884 which I'm assuming
when Jazz was popular
you know it's outside the like there's
like like corporate building plazas all
around us and there's buildings like
almost like Standalone it's really cool
yeah they really they held out and thank
God they did because I mean like I'm
saying man this might be the best burger
in New York City we're going to be the
judges about Joe yeah speaking of which
uh burgers are we going to be ordering
yeah King Cole baby we're getting the
Cadillac I feel that like we got bit we
were getting bacon anyway you know they
have other ones that look like fun but I
think Bacon's a nice
get that on every single one I got to
get my fill of that good crispy American
bacon while I'm sorry right that's right
you can't get the pepper bacon anywhere
in in London you can in some places but
it's way less common particularly on a
burger in a kind of what is effectively
like a pub slash bar but yeah well
obviously with a bit more of a fancy
dining you can't bring your own bacon to
the pub uh you could smuggle some in
maybe get some like pocket Meats going
with your own ranch yeah yeah I like the
vibe in here yeah it's busy the chicken
make the checkered red and white this
thing's very classic now old school they
filmed uh some madman stuff here like
they came around Mad Men and it's a
perfect fitting like getting to work
drinking all day at work then going to
lunch to drink martinis sure before you
go back to the office and drink more
cool and they get loaded on a happy hour
before you drive home maybe you're happy
up until the driving time drive your
giant tank Cadillac
out to Long Island to get home at like 9
00 PM for dinner
and unwind with two more glasses of
scotch
it's a miracle anyone made it out of
that generation honestly yeah how do we
don't just go extinct in like the 50s
thank you
oh my man that was a big bucket thank
you Eduardo I love you so much looks
delicious brace yourself we gotta talk
about before we eat it okay also stacked
this one yes thick cut of tomato lettuce
on the bottom okay I like the lettuce on
the bottom because I know it makes
everything go every direction yeah they
kind of isolated from the rest of
tapping is very smart very smart a
thicker more smokier bacon this might be
the best bacon you're going to see all
day my buddy this looks crispy as hell
now did you notice onions underneath for
some reason you're gonna put your onions
in the bag yeah of course um the pickles
on the side again you can pickle thank
you thank you I feel like you might skip
but I'm definitely doing Burger some
assembly required yeah dude hit it with
the pickles
this thing is huge this thing is just
dripping oh my God my plate looks like
the floor of a slaughterhouse this is
perfect ready I think so bite my gas do
this my optimal angle for bite
wow
oh look on the inside there let's cook
perfectly medium rare
sub medium wrap yeah perfect
another place where they asked us how we
wanted it cooked which again I think is
a good time
cooked to order
as well how do you want to cook this
code for we're paying attention
this is so good this is so fantastic
serious about remember the consistency
of the bacon on this one might be
perfect it's crunchier than normal I
like has a little bit of bikes
everything's so soft had a few concerns
about the assembly maybe because when
you have things like one big slice of
tomato Big Slice of lettuce and large
pieces of bacon sometimes when you bite
into it you can kind of like pull
everything out by mistake but it's
really holding together I'm liking the
bun as well because somehow despite the
amount of moisture that's been coming
off this the Buns like holding together
doing its job it's not falling apart at
all no oh wow
wow wow this fries nice crispy Joe
I wish the UK did bacon like this I'm
willing to admit when the US does
something better than the UK I think
Bacon's a good example because you guys
even as bacon sandwiches the bacon buddy
Bubby buddy
I can't believe you guys are literally
having bacon sandwiches and nobody's
like hey why don't we mix is a little
bit crispier yeah and that one person
has drawn that has made that conclusion
I wish we would I've had too many like
depressing
very pale rashes of bacon it's not
Bacon's a real bummer over there what do
you think about the um the beef patty
itself this one's like the perfect size
and with all the toppings
together just so good I think they can
only get away with putting this many
other toppings on it because the Patty
is so thick and juicy and Meaty not
falling apart also packed in there man
which I love
I did think that I'm not getting as much
of the cheese coming through in the
cheeseburger part of it well this one
like the cheese has lots of impresses in
there we want a cheeseburger you really
want to taste the cheese right I think I
could like come and go on that one I do
think that American cheese is the best
cheese for a cheeseburger
melts without splitting hear that I also
don't personally want a ton of cheese on
a cheeseburger and it might sound a bit
weird for me it's more like a little
accent to the Burger really and almost
more of like a textural thing as well
well this is amazing I feel great but um
I think I'm a rosary buddy so we do as
much as I'd like to hang out here have a
few more drinks maybe move to martinis I
feel like uh it's time to go yeah a
couple more Burgers then we're searching
in martinis
yeah too fast man
and then I did it too
[Applause]
after that we headed over to Brooklyn
for our next burger at the Long Island
Bar
I visited the Long Island Bar it's been
open since 1951 and also I think I like
this place too because it has more of an
American menu there's cheese curds and
deviled eggs I want you to try too yeah
yeah never tried either of those things
they sound like classic American Foods
would you agree no definitely yeah also
kind of dig the art deco vibe in the
spot too right it's really cool 50s
diner Vibes yeah I feel like tradition
has kind of been like a Hallmark of this
burger tour so far it feels like we kind
of step back and [__] a time capsule I'm
really liking it all right but I am
dying for a burger how about you yeah I
think I can do maybe one slash two more
Burgers let's do it
thank you
[Music]
there we go look at these this is a
spread what's up dude this is the
American flag in here like you know
where you are I'm taking mine not you
leave yours in this looks like a Krabby
Patty oh yeah it's like the perfect
cartoon Burger all right which honestly
makes me want to eat it so badly no time
to waste I'm taking a bite I'm going in
I can't wait to taste this bacon I don't
want to accidentally eat the American
flag so I'm gonna move that one
[Music]
um
good
oh man get me with this
and what the Special Sauce I have on
here okay
that's crazy this is the secret weapon
right here just bacon
I need to know how they've done this
without because
the shape is amazing
and the crisp on that something you
don't see in the UK either the batter
the fries that's the fries that's the
most American thing I've ever eaten yeah
right instead of it being a one thick
one two
half thickness ones double it up with
the cheese in the middle I'm saying like
there's pickles in the middle yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you see that they've
like the layouts it looks really well
sealed in deliciousness yeah oh this is
so good and the bun a bit more texture
to the outside
this thing's ridiculous fantastic yeah
there's like you can tell a lot of
thought has gone into the Assembly of
this burger and I like because there's
two patties there's like a meat to
cheese ratio that's better here than
it's been anywhere else yes don't let
that precious cheese go to waste my man
and this end me the star of the show The
Secret Weapon
bacon floss Seminole it's fantastic
bacon spiral so I love the American vibe
to this the owner is from Wisconsin yes
you're an also from Wisconsin a cheese
curds she's good I don't know if you've
had one of these before but you know
what this is
ball of deep fried goodness that's all
you need cheese right here incurred from
fried boom get in here get in here what
is that like ranch sauce yeah
I mean it doesn't eat it it's so
flavorful it's so good
he's bringing these in from Wisconsin
right
really pleasing texture on that yeah
it's great you can see there's like an
obsession in the midwest yeah wow nice
and cheery not overly cheesy no more
just like a sort of
chewy Savory that's a snack this is a
Midwest snack right here you can go go
to town and get a few more I'm concerned
for the health of midwesterners if this
is a snack but oh they're fine very
tasty I don't think there's really an
obesity problem in the midwest at all no
those those are colorful little white
guys in front of you deviled eggs
hard-boiled eggs they take out the yolk
ball whip it up with spices in like and
re-insert it in there so you know it's a
hard-boiled egg it has like a softer
texture to it okay and this place
usually they'll throw in like paprika or
something to give a little bit of a kick
yep they have their own house-made hot
sauce okay so there's a little twists
get in there why are they called uh
deviled eggs why are these like Unholy
because they're a sinful pleasure you uh
joining me on this one or are you
watching your cholesterol yeah I'm
watching my cholesterol
see the reaction
like that yeah right
no hot sauce man
nice gentle heat with their Competitive
Edge I think here is that they're
leaning into you know the americana-ness
of it right a double burger dripping
with cheese delicious sauce ridiculously
good bacon I don't know where this
Bacon's from no uh but I absolutely love
it battered fries battered cheese curds
Devil's eggs and martinis yeah I mean
this is like a niche That You Don't See
too often in New York or anywhere
outside of the Midwest it's really kind
of unique there's nothing like this in
the UK yeah right I've not had this
experience before it's Cobble Hill
it's not the tourist center of New York
City certainly not uh but definitely
worth coming out to or people live in
Brooklyn visiting uh but yeah this
Burger's ridiculous it's so good it's a
thin Patty but it's not smashed not a
Smash Burger because we're not getting
like kind of like golden brown crispy
crust on the outside
but I will say it's like very well
seasoned so it's very flavorful they did
lettuce no tomato no onion in the reason
right I don't think so no
just a lot of pickles cheese that
incredible bacon yeah the meat in the
taco and this one which honestly I kind
of think is how a cheeseburger should be
yeah I agree yeah let the meat give the
talking fantastic
oh and wash down this refreshing Martini
cheers my good man
you look like you're enjoying that
should have gotten a beer all right
Killer Burger this place is getting
packed I feel like we're taking a
valuable real estate here got one more
spot to take you you want to go I do
yeah popular spot let's clear out and
give him some space let's go
I wanted to show Harry a place that
takes a slightly more creative approach
with their burgers so we headed up to
Rolos in Queens
I don't know anything I don't know
anything about electricity I want to say
that I don't know
electricity electricity like nothing
okay so we've established on anything
I'm pretty sure that's not right
no that does not look good
I can't be safe no no way the electric
company got in the cherry picker and got
up there was like
yeah looks good yeah looks good cool
Harold Joseph we've eaten our way
through New York City via Burgers we
have last place here in Queens Rolos
one L not two not to be confused with
the very sweet uh chocolate candy with
the caramel Center Burger here's
supposed to be bomb one to end the day
here little outdoor dining Alfresco how
you feeling I'll be honest not great I
think my eyes why I think my eyes might
have been bigger than my stomach with
the shoe oh really as you as you'll
remember I was kind of putting away the
entire burger for the first couple of
spots thinking I was plain sailing I
don't recall saying anything no I don't
think anyone did you know if only
someone had told me that would have been
great yeah so it's it's the crew's fault
yeah I blame everyone except myself yeah
very smart man you are becoming an
American more and more every day hey
I've made it so the House Burgers here
everything is fresh I believe the meat
blend is 75 lean 25 fat beef so you're
gonna be getting a nice savory flavor in
there everything cooked an open
Wood-Fired grilled and not flat top
which is a distinction from all the
other places I've been to today they
only make a limited number of burgers
each day yeah so it's a lot more modern
than the other places we've been today
yeah it's much more of a kind of like a
cool hip spot yeah rather than a very
classic New York style institution yeah
music's playing lights are dim candles
are lit you know nice place to take a
date maybe yeah you know a mix of
everything if this video is a little
longer I would have taken to White
Castle but apparently that doesn't count
thank you
perfect
thank you I want to tell you about this
place first impressions what are you
thinking I was trying to get a photo of
the boat yeah
you could be real let's go real quick
real quick because this is a photogenic
Burger I would say yeah I mean how
beautiful does this thing look it's
pretty gorgeous yeah I will say right
off the bat this looks very different to
the other bows we tried today look it's
going to hear the sear in the top of the
bunion searing the Buns see that before
right we got the bacon look at the color
on this bacon by the way yeah it was
different than the bacon that we've had
but it looks really good yeah it's like
a really bright red two beef patties
there's like some caramelized onion on
there as well yeah this is horses and
cheese this is I don't think they're
smashed Burgers but they look more
Smashburger like much more like a Smash
Burger because you can see you've got
like bits of kind of caramelization on
there it's like dark crust on the burger
yeah pretty impressive might be
something to do with the way it's cooked
it's cooked over the wood fire yeah no
yeah
you're lost in the burger right now
okay man last one of the day cheers my
guy
oh wow the onions on this thing too
this thing is fantastic you can just
take the difference with the Wood Fired
meat versus something that was on the
grill top they put cheese in between
both patties such easier but the sauce
too is incredible yeah I can't get over
the onions actually yeah whatever
they're doing these onions they look
like like dipped in like garlic butter
or whatever right garlic caramelized
that's incredible a little bit of
sweetness yeah yeah I really like the
mustard sauce on this actually it's like
a mustard mayo type thing
a little bit of pepperiness yeah it's
got a bit of a a dijon-ness to it yeah
yeah yeah everything's working so well
together this is one of the more juicy
ones we've had today too right in a
crowded field yeah I feel like they've
all been pretty juicy that's like a
recurring beam but this one definitely
again you squeeze it a lot of juices are
running out of it the onion juices all
just kind of mingles into one delicious
broth really impressive it's probably
the most inventive Burger we've had
today all right definitely look at the
color on that on that bacon yeah so
maybe not as crispy as some of the other
bacon that we've had no no no no but the
flavor is fantastic yeah the flavor's
definitely locked in there I mean I
think everything about this is really
like all the positives of flavors are
jumping out of me it's because it's
cooked in wood fire yep that is just
unlocked the flavor and the meat that we
weren't really getting from the other
Burgers it's flavorful right yeah with
the the grilled onions no other Burger
today has been topped with like such
flavorful extras doesn't make sense
right price wise this burger lands in
the middle it's 18 but 3x dollars for
the bacon definitely worth it so 21
bucks for the burger and a big long
pepper I've been eating your Burgers all
day I feel like if I was having a normal
meal Justice Burger would would hit the
spot for me it's a big burger it is a
big bug I think this would fill you up
yeah I also think like location wise
we're a bit further out than we have
been for the other ones yeah the first
couple were like very Central Manhattan
based then we kind of moved more out
towards Brooklyn and now we're in
Ridgewood which I guess isn't as much of
a touristy area like a neighborhood yeah
location considered I think this is more
of a high-end high-end uh Burger well I
might be kind of in the like middle to
high end of the price scale I do think
you're getting a lot of quality for your
money they clearly take a lot of care
over their meat the way they prepare it
the way they cook it and it does show
through in the final product it's a very
very tasty burger yeah very tasty
not very considerate of people filming
around here on the roads are rude I
think we're all impressed with how loud
that was oh me too yeah hard choices
have to be made Harry
I get it it's fun
[Laughter]
it's a motorbike and bus area which is
really convenient
oh my gosh four of the best we did the
London Burger episode so I had to uh
respond with the New York City Burger
episode overall what'd you think of New
York City Burgers today I do think we've
had some really Fantastic Burgers
overall yeah I also like how the
different spots are kind of like
represented different parts of I guess
New York culture as well from the very
traditional kind of bar Tavern kind of
Vibes to the more classic Americana
Diner style and of course the people who
are doing it a little bit differently
putting their own spin on the classics
yeah I like the variation that we've had
today as well I like how some of them
have been the more thick cut patties
yeah some of them have gone for the
thinner double options all of them have
been really really juicy all of them
have been pretty flavorful I will say I
don't know compared to some of the
London options I don't feel like New
York is doing it necessarily a lot
better than London is Joe might disagree
I disagree but I feel like in terms of
the actual like beef quality of those
meats I do feel like UK farmers are
holding it down no I don't agree with
that
all right our beef is superior to yours
all right I don't know how much clearer
I can put it USA is beef so break it
down what is your favorite and why
um if I had to pick a favorite you do of
the burgers contractually obligated to
pick a favorite I am I think if we had
to pick a favorite
same guy
[Music]
oh my God very tough decision I think my
favorite of the four we had today yeah
Long Island Bar wow really you look
surprised I guess I'm not no that was a
really good burger really good burger
yeah that was my number two hey the vibe
in the place was really good yeah I like
it in there very like classic Americana
style really cool I think the thing that
stood out for me though was the care
they took when they were assembling that
burger the way that it was layered
ingredients kind of equally distributed
throughout the burger yeah fantastic the
beef itself really well seasoned really
great flavor lots of like pepper and
salt and you can even put another
seasoning on that one and yeah I did it
really really stood out to me wow yeah I
just think overall
that was my best burger wow how about
you that was my number two number two
okay but number one if Dr because jg's
and PJs those places to me are like New
York City the vibe they had that like
one Manhattan we're popping in a burger
getting a beer depending on what time it
is the Ambiance the fact that they're
doing it the same way they've been doing
for you know with a hundred years or
whatever and they've been in that long
clearly they're doing something right so
both those Burgers had like a taste like
a classic traditional burger taste that
I do enjoy now Long Island Bar your
favorite I picked up on all the things
that you just said would have maybe have
been my favorite of the day but
the best burger that I had today
is our boy Rolos this one right here the
flame grilled the quality of the burger
the 75-25 ratio of lean the fat this
burger is fantastic I'm very impressed
how good it is I love the bacon and this
everything about it the bun how it works
together the second I've been in this
I'm like yeah we have a winner we've
been eating burgers all day that's a
testament how good this Burgers we're on
our way over here I'm like no another
burger place and then a bit into it I'm
like I'm so glad I came here it's a
fantastic Burger the other three places
also amazing I think the quality of the
meat like I say probably highest at
Rolos yeah really had that beefy meaty
flavor that I really want when I bite
into a burger so I do think that if it
was purely a case of like the flavor of
the beef burger itself okay they may
have been my number one okay I think
overall I was factoring some things into
my decision like the kind of vibe in
there I just love the Americana it was
like a little bit kitschy in the Long
Island Bar ah I see but I love that as a
tourist I think that's what people want
when they come to New York for an
authentic Burger experience I never
thought of it like factored into my
decision the burger itself is still
fantastic I'm not just recommending it
on the vibe but yeah I think all in all
as a total package recommending this to
other tourists that would be why I'm
making my decisions I'm so tired I'm
really tired I'm still very tired people
can help watch this video the Sun is
going down we're both gonna get a gout
after this trip bring it on baby
to White Castle so like us
foreign